it's a tough one right here man first of
all I want to thank y'all for allowing
me the opportunity to speak here today
it's a real honor to be able to appear
here and show love on behalf of my
friend my brother a great man a great
leader a great father a great teacher
and a great friend
Nipsey Hussle and I want to start off by
showing some love to Lauren and nipsey
children I want to send Lauren a lot of
love for being the beloved Queen to our
king see what we lose focus on is that
every real black man he's a real black
woman in his life
[Applause]
every time I would see nip and Lauren
out they've reminded me of me and my
wife it was it was like black excellence
you loved the CD so with that being said
Lauren my wife my family my kids we're
here for you whatever you need whatever
you need you need a shoulder to cry on
if you need a hug you just need to get
away we're here for you we love you baby
girl we always have we always will
[Applause]
there wasn't y'all I'm trying to stay
strong for the homeboy net right now
stay down with me stand out with me I
got you guys I got something
next I want to acknowledge nipsey's
father seekers nip has always benefited
from having a strong man in his life and
his father clearly did a great job
[Applause]
we showed them how to be a strong man a
strong black man
it was always amazing when I can go to
the store because I would go to the
store my own solo no security pull up in
the morning
Pop's being me and I could just see the
look on his face and he was so proud of
his boys for doing something in the
community and doing something positive
that was inspiring and pops I look at
your face every time I come in the store
and I just sing to joy and I just want
you to know that you may have lost a son
but you picked up another son of me
and now I got to send the bundle of love
to nipsey's mother lord have mercy
what great strength that she showed she
showed a lot of great stress she helped
us out this weekend mother I want to say
this to you dearly without reading when
you said what you said she really
uplifted us we had no understanding we
had no we had no nothing and you gave us
what we needed he gave us the sense and
the purpose to know and understand and
it was alright you made us understand it
it was alright because we did not
understand at all we had no clarity and
we was more or less concerned about you
and concerned about Lauren and concerned
about the family but you made us feel
good we want to thank you for that
mother for being strong and giving us
our strip
[Applause]
I also want to thank all the other
mothers in the house like now that's
been praying for Misty's mother that's
been praying for Lauren we appreciate
all that love for you women and I want
to say this if it so happens to be that
your kids die before you nipsey's mother
prepared us for this day in the future
thank you mother I didn't grow up with
me I didn't grow up with him in your
neighborhood as a kid but I watched lip
draw in front of me I watched him grow
into a full-grown man and an incredible
young businessman I still remember the
first time when he pushed up on me with
his team most rappers when they push up
on Snoop Dogg with a chain this is day
line hey don't listen to my music I can
make you a million dollars nipsey's line
was ain't homie listen to my music just
give it a listen that's it no record
deal you don't want to get put home so
to me he had vision to know and
understand it I don't want to be handed
out nothing I'm gonna come get mine
but at the same time but at the same
time looking for that clarification
looking for the that confirmation
you know just listen to it home the
first time I got to see the I don't
listen to I told you that I can't be
wondering with him um I came back gave
me your CD at football practice cowboy
listening that I was at football
practice then about a week later to see
he gave me another city so I'm rolling
up a blunt in the backseat of the car on
the CD
I saw open his CD up all right the homie
no no you know the story already so I'm
just telling y'all so y'all being like
so I took the CD out and I pop the CD in
I was like him cuz it's hard something
like a man cut little homie hard cut let
me get out woody long story short we
ended up connecting winded up making
music together we ended up making up a
brotherhood we ended up creating a bond
we created something that was special
and and what was crazy was when he first
started a lot of people was like you
know he looked like me he didn't see
that but I don't think so I think you
know it was the fact that he was tall he
was like he had braids
he had that LA mentality and he claimed
the gang so I mean it was naturally be
categorized but one thing that me and
nip had was a kind spirit we had that
spirit of love of like Sam said just
magnate me like people magnate to to
Snoop Dogg in a magnet towards nifty
it's like well we met each other it was
like a magnet coming together we had the
same spirit but what was crazy was you
new mentality was stronger than a rapper
that's been in the game for 15 years and
I'll give you an example of that one of
the first conversations me if she had he
was talking to me about hey you need to
do a
amusement park good doggy Lynn cuz
I'm like for real like yeah cuz we're
40-ounce roller coasters it won't sink
if you sleep dog cuz everybody comes to
you gonna say you'd come check your
movie park I might cut your trip so he
kept like every time I was seeing he
would always bring it up he but bring it
up so like the fifth time he said it to
me or was it the sixth time yeah the
sixth time he said it to me
let me get politically correct yeah cut
his fixed time he said it to me I said
Nick why don't you just do it for me cuz
I don't understand the dynamics of what
you're saying
pleasure I'm always schooling I'm ABCD
you didn't went off into the matrix you
got it
so with that being said Nick ended up
creating a square and he ended up buying
property and he ended up having things
like vector 90 and he ended up doing
things in the community and and he built
his own doggy later he built his own
world he built his own thing that people
from around the world that's starting to
come to take pictures up standing in
front of immortalizes me the things that
he wanted for me he did for himself but
he had vision for me that I didn't even
have for myself
so I want to thank you mother and father
bringing in see into this world but
given us Nick
[Applause]
if the balls there for those that new
Nipsey Hussle personally you knew he had
nothing but love for every gang member
from Southern California I don't care
what neighborhood she was from one
conversation that me and nip had once
the point of time was cuz you know the
trays like your music too cuz you like
no they don't cuz I'm like you need to
make everybody like our music cuz it
ain't no it ain't like that when you
make music you come from the dirt one
thing about the neighborhood we're gonna
respect another man from another
neighborhood even if he answered my
neighborhood if he come from what we
come from and I explained that to Nick
and when I was explaining it to him he
was he was getting it but he wasn't
getting it but I was like look at what
you're doing you make records where yg
you made records for game you made
records were proudly you making records
we're blood Crippen and bloods make your
records and y'all really love each other
y'all bonding with each other y'all
pulling up together you and they
neighborhoods you loving them and they
love you you are a piece of the kidney
that's what you are and the reason why I
noticed it because that's what I am you
know real recognize real I know what he
is I know what he was and the marathon
is gonna continue look at the love look
at the spirit this man I'm on my
anything like this this man got a letter
from Barack Obama man
my last words will be for God so loved
the world that he gave us a good trip
the lake great neighborhood yeah rest in
peace huh name
[Applause]